[Musik]
guten Abend und willkommen zu den heute
Nachrichten Christian Auto ist auch
dabei für den Sport mit einer
Überraschung skispring guten Abend
schauen wir auf die nachrichtenthen von
heute zwischen truer und Protest das
israelische Militär tötet versehentlich
drei Geiseln in Tel Aviv fordern
Demonstranten ein neues Abkommen mit der
Hamas Eskalation im Roten Meer Angriffe
auf frach bedrohen eine der wichtigsten
Handelsstraßen der
Welt und der erste Weltcupsieg mit 33
Jahren Pius Paschke gewinnt überraschend
das Skispringen im schweizerischen
Engelberg israels Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu spricht von einer
unerträglichen Tragödie drei von der
Hamas entführte Israelis sind tot
erschossen im Gazastreifen aus Versehen
von den eigenen Soldaten obwohl die jung
Männer offenbar eine weiße Fahne
schwenkten in Israel hascht
Fassungslosigkeit Trauer und Wut der
Druck auf die Regierung wächst Susanne
Santina berichtet eine der Getöteten
Geiseln wurde heute beerdigt große
Trauer in Israel um drei junge Männer
die von den Hamas Terroristen aus ihrem
kiburz entführt worden waren und
versehentlich von israelischen Soldaten
erschossen wurden wie konnte dieser
tragische Irrtum der Streitkräfte in
Gaza Passieren der Generalleutnant
versucht zu erklären
die Soldaten treffen auf viele
Terroristen die sich als Zivilisten
kleiden sie müssen auf den
Sekundenbruchteilen entscheiden es kann
der Unterschied zwischen Leben und Tod
sein der Militärchef räumt aber auch ein
dass es einen Verstoß gegen die
Vorschriften gab Proteste von tausenden
Menschen auch heute wieder in Tel Aviv
fast täglich kommen sie zusammen werfen
der Regierung vor zu wenig für die
Freilassung der Geis zu
tun für die Befreiung vor und bringt die
Weltgemeinschaft hinter diesen Plan ich
flehe euch
an nicht die Soldaten tragen die Schuld
sondern diejenigen die sie hingeschickt
haben
129 Menschen sind noch in der Gewalt der
Terroristen sie werden so lange weiter
protestieren bis sie alle befreit
sind Henriette deier ist in telaviv auf
dem Platz wo sich immer die Angehörigen
der Geiseln versammeln was erwarten die
Menschen von der Regierung
jetzt
hier auf dem Platz der Geiseln und
Vermissten findet gerade eine
Schweigeminute statt viele Menschen sind
gekommen sie fordern dass die Regierung
endlich einen Plan umreißen soll wie sie
die Geiseln zurückbringen will die
Regierung um Regierungspräsidenten
Netanyahu trifft sich heute das
kriegskabinett hier hinter uns im
Verteidigungsministerien Ministerium um
zu beraten welchen Plan es geben könnte
die Versammlung hier wird später
weiterziehen zum
Verteidigungsministerium dort wollen sie
den Eingang besetzen und sagen sie
bleiben sie bleiben bis es eine Lösung
für die Geiseln gibt danke schön nach
Tel Aviv Henriette de mier war
das dieser Krieg zerstört so viele Leben
traumatisiert so viele Familien auf
beiden Seiten unsere reporterin Anne
Brühl hat in Israel mit Müttern
gesprochen deren Kinder als Soldaten im
Gazastreifen im Einsatz sind
die hanuka Kerzen brennen immer noch zu
Hause bei ruttik in Jerusalem Licht das
die Dunkelheit vertreibt noch nie sagt
sie war das wichtiger als heute zwei
ihrer Söhne sind Soldaten in
Gaza ich glaube die Menschen verstehen
nicht dass unsere Kinder das nicht
machen wollen wir wollen das auch nicht
aber wir fühlen wir haben keine andere
Wahl Rut Adriana und Rebecca kennen sich
seitdem ihre Söhne zusammen im
Kindergarten waren sie alle kämpfen
jetzt in Gaza die Frauen versuchen
einmal in der Woche zusammen zu backen
um sich irgendwie abzulenken es ist
schrecklich es gibt keinen Weg in
Kontakt zu bleiben es gibt überhaupt
keine
Kommunikation in Gedanken sind sie immer
bei ihren
Kindern was Gott verhindern mag wenn sie
jemand töten müssten das ist etwas ich
glaube das kann niemand sie sind dazu
nicht gemacht so haben wir sie nicht
erzogen so sind sie einfach nicht das
ist sehr
verstörend
von einem aber sind alle Frauen
überzeugt nach dem Überfall der Hamas
auf Israel gibt es keine Alternative zu
diesem
Krieg es hat nichts mit Rache zu tun es
geht um das Überleben des jüdischen
Staates und der Juden auf der ganzen
Welt sie alle waren in den letzten
Wochen auf Beerdigungen bei Kameraden
ihrer Söhne den Gedanken auch sie zu
verlieren erlauben sie sich nicht lass
uns darüber nicht sprechen wir sprechen
nicht
darüber halala das Gebäck ist nach
jüdischer Tradition verbunden mit einem
persönlichen Gebet einem für die
Sicherheit ihrer
Söhne seit einigen Wochen versorgt
Ägypten Patienten aus dem Gazastreifen
um das Land dabei zu unterstützen hat
die Bundeswehr medizinische Hilfsgüter
nach Kairo gebracht an Bord waren unter
anderem Beatmungsgeräte und Brutkästen
für Säuglinge für die kommende Woche
plant die Luftwaffe weitere Hilfsflüge
dann sollen auch Zelte für die Menschen
im Gasastreifen geliefert
werden seit Beginn dieses Krieges gibt
es fast täglich Angriffe auf
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer auch heute
hat ein britisches Kriegsschiff eine
Drohne abgefangen das Rote Meer gilt als
wichtigste Handelsroute zwischen
fororderasien Afrika und Europa die
Angriffe kommen aus dem Yemen offenbar
aus dem Gebiet das die von Iran
unterstützten hui Rebellen kontrollieren
auch die aljasra wurde angegriffen ein
Schiff der deutschen räderei Harar Leut
luten leinhoss hat mehr sie sind zum
Schrecken der weltschifffahrt geworden
die hui Rebellen aus dem Jemen hier
Filmen Sie sich selbst wie sie Mitte
November einen riesigen autofrachter
Kern und mit Besatzung entführen die
deutsche haleut hat erstmals alle
Fahrten durchs Rote Meer und den Sues
Kanal
gestoppt wir werden Montag entscheiden
wie wir weiter vorgehen ob wir den Sues
Kanal wieder für sicherer halten als er
jetzt im Moment ist oder ob wir weiter
um weeg nehmen werden auch die größte
containerräderei der Welt MSC schickt
vorerst keine Schiffe mehr durch das
Rote Meer damit hat der globale
Warenaustausch jetzt ein doppeltes
Problem denn auch der Panama Kanal fällt
derzeit wegen Wassermangels teilweise
aus die Folgen könnten drastisch sein
von POS nach Singapur sind es
normalerweise 13 Tage ohne Sueskanal
werden daraus 30 Tage und wegen der
Probleme in Panama müssen viele Schiffe
von Shanghai nach New York derzeit
ebenfalls durch den Sueskanal und es
droht nun der Weite Umweg um Afrika in
der Tat ist das quasi ein
jahrhundertphänomen dass im Moment beide
Kanäle nicht vollumfänglich befahren
werden können und das ist natürlich für
den Welthandel für die gesamte schiffaht
ein massives Problem die Führung der hi
Rebellen droht heute mit weit Angriffen
ihr Ziel ist es die Hamas im
Gazastreifen zu unterstützen sagt ein
jemenexerte den wir im Oman erreichen
bei his handelt es sich um eine ganz
ganz klar
antiamerikanische
antiisraelische und auch zu großen
Teilen antisaudische Bewegung die
US-Marine meldet vor wenigen Stunden 14
huidrohnen über dem Roten Meer
abgeschossen zu haben Forderungen nach
mehr militärischem Schutz werden lauter
die Europäer sollten das tun was die
Amerikaner schon lange machen nämlich
den den Seeraum dort mit überwachen die
zivile Schiffahrt muss geschützt werden
es ist die freie Seefahrt die geschützt
werden muss wir als Deutsche können
einen Beitrag dazu leisten denkbar sei
vieles unterstützende
Aufklärungsflugzeuge und Soldaten in
internationalen Einsatzzentralen bis hin
zu Marineschiffen dann aber mit
Bundestagsmandat nach Deutschland
Finanzminister Lindner plant eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse es geht um die
sogenannte
konjunkturkomponente das habe nichts mit
der aktuellen Haushaltssituation zu tun
sagte Lindner dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland die konjunkturkomponente
erlaubt in konjunkturell schlechten
Zeiten grundsätzlich die Aufnahme neuer
Kredite die in besseren Zeiten zu
begleichen sind eine grundlegende
Änderung der Schuldenbremse wie von SPD
und Grünen gefordert lehnt Lindner
weiterhin ab gut Monate nach der
hässischen Landtagswahl haben CDU und
SPD den Weg freigemacht für schwarzrot
der kleine Parteitag der CDU stimmte für
die Annahme des
Koalitionsvertrags nach kontroverser
Debatte gab es ein ja auch von den
Sozialdemokraten bei ihrem
außerordentlichen Parteitag für SPD
Landeschefin fäer ist es keine
Liebesheirat sondern eine
vernunftsehe wer den Umweltbonus für
sein neues E-Auto bekt möchte der muss
spätestens morgen dafür den Antrag
einreichen ab Montag wird nichts mehr
angenommen teilte das
Wirtschaftsministerium mit eigentlich
hätte bis Ende 2024 Geld fließen sollen
das früher Schluss ist war seit Mittwoch
bekannt als sich die ampelparteien auf
Einsparungen beim Haushalt in
Milliardenhöhe geeinigt
hatten nach Serbien jetzt einem EU
Beitrittskandidaten bei den vorgezogenen
Parlaments und kommunalw W morgen
fordert ein Oppositionsbündnis die
rechtspopulistische regierende
Fortschrittspartei von Präsident
wutschic heraus eine Abstimmung die vor
dem Hintergrund erneuter Spannungen mit
dem Kosovo stattfindet Brita
Hilpert Alexander wutit steht gar nicht
zur Wahl und doch geht es nur um ihn bei
den Parlamentswahlen morgen will der
serbische Präsident seine Machtbasis
sichern ich erwarte dass wir siegen die
absolute Mehrheit im
parlamenting die Neuwahl war eine
Forderung monatelanger Proteste anlass
waren zwei Amokläufe mit 18 Toten dafür
machten tausende ein Klima der Gewalt
verantwortlich das hätten Regierung und
regierungsnahe Medien befördert hasshze
und ein permanenter krisenmodus all das
nutzt wuc um Wähler hinter sich zu
sammeln so auch zum Thema Kosovo die
Gewalt von Serben gegen KF und Kosovo
Polizei erklärt er mit Terror gegen
Serben stellt sich auf die Seite von
Gewalttätern seine Allgegenwart in den
Medien ist wic Trumpf 2023 hat er sich
bis Ende November im Fernsehen 260 mal
an die Nation
gewandt gegen Gewalt nennt sich das
wichtigste Parteienbündnis gegen wuic
ihre Chancen sind gering gibt auch der
Chef der größten Oppositionspartei
draganilas zu er sei Freund der Mafia
und des Westens so werde er
heruntergeschrieben und
warnt W ist nicht für die EU er möchte
ein großes Spiel spielen so etwas wie
Tito sein mit Russland mit China er ist
vor allem für sich
selbst Umfragen sehen wit vorn Serbien
wird mit ihm wohl ein schwieriger EU
Beitrittskandidat
bleiben mehr als 148 Millionen Dollar
Strafe so viel muss der frühere
trumpanwalt Rudi Giuliani wegen
Verleumdung zahlen das hat eine
Geschworenen Jury entschieden Giuliani
hatte zwei Wahlhelferinnen betrug bei
der Präsidentschaftswahl 2020
vorgeworfen er behauptete damals
fälschlicherweise sie hätten
abstimmungszettel für Donald Trump
weggeworfen daraufhin waren die Frauen
von Trump Anhängern angefeindet und
bedroht
worden für die 68 000 Beschäftigten in
der nordwestdeutschen Stahl Industrie
gibt es einen neuen Tarifvertrag
IG Metall und Arbeitgeber einigten sich
auf 3000 € Inflationsausgleich in zwei
Schritten und
5,5% mehr Geld ab
2025 als zukunftsweisend bezeichnet die
Gewerkschaft die Vereinbarungen zur
Arbeitszeitverkürzung bei teilweisem
Lohnausgleich seit dem Krieg zwischen
Israel und der Hamas haben in
Deutschland antisemitische Vorfälle
sprunghaft zu genommen auch an
Universitäten das ist ein Thema beim
jüdischen Gemeindetag der noch bis
morgen in Berlin stattfindet erst am
Donnerstag wurden an der FU Berlin
jüdische Studenten am Betreten des
hörsals gehindert Markus
groß Polizeieinsatz vor zwei Tagen an
der Freien Universität Berlin der hörsal
wird geräumt linke Aktivisten hatten ihn
zuvor besetzt deren palästiner
Solidarität schlug teilweise in Hetze
gegen Israel um
vor dem hörsal Rangelein zwischen
proalästinensischen und jüdischen
Studierenden es war eine schreckliche
Situation und dass die Werte die wir uns
nach diesem nach dieser Geschichte
aufgebaut haben dass die teilweise mit
Füßen getreten worden sind und das auch
noch für viele Stunden von der
Universitätsleitung zugelassen worden
ist das bricht uns allen so ein bisschen
das Herz sage ich mal antisemitische
Schmierereien an den Toiletten der
Universität Israelhass verbreitet auf
Flugblättern der Gazakrieg führt an
deutschen Hochschulen zu erheblichen
Konflikten es brodelt in und vor den
hörseelen und in einem eher linken
Milieu was wir in den letzten Jahren
gerade auf Israel bezogenen
Antisemitismus mitbekommen ist ja das
ganz gezielt soziale Bewegung wie die
Klima Bewegung ähm Quere Bewegung
antikapitalistische Bewegung auch
gezielt angesprochen werden auch dort
ganz klar Israel feindlicher bis hin zu
offen antisemitische Position zu
Mainstream oder zum Teil dieser sozialen
Bewegung zu machen die Hochschule ist
ein beliebter Ort um sozusagen diese
Kämpfe äm auszutragen wie dem wachsenden
Antisemitismus begegnen das ist vor
allem ein Thema beim jüdischen
Gemeindetag Vorfälle wie an den
Universitäten beunruhigen ich finde das
fürchterlich aber wir müssen auch sagen
dass das nicht generell für alle
Universitäten gibt im großstädtischen
Bereich allerdings deutlich vermehrt
nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir auch starken
Widerstand der jüdischen Studierenden
die trotzdem sagen das ist unsere Uni
das ist unsere Stadt das ist unser Land
und wir werden uns nicht vertreiben
lassen dagegen halten das wollen auch
Sie Solidarität mit Israel nach den
Vorfällen an der Freien Universität ihre
Forderung mehr Sicherheit für jüdische
Studierende das Hochwasser am Rhein
entstanden durch Regen und Tauwetter hat
viele Orts seinen Höchststand erreicht
vor allem am rein in stank garshausen in
Rheinlandpfalz stehen die Uferbereiche
weiträumig unter Wasser bis Mitte der
Woche ist mit sinkenden Pegelständen zu
rechnen entspannt hat sich die
Hochwassersituation an der Donau und den
Zuflüssen und jetzt zu den deutschen
Skispringern Christin deren Höhenflug
hält an heute stauen alle ganz besonders
diesmal flog Pius paschka aus
Kiefersfelden von der Großschanze in
Engelberg am weitesten äußerst
nervenstark sicherte er sich mit 33
Jahren den ersten Weltcupsieg seiner
Karriere so richtig fassen kann es Pios
Paschke noch nicht umringt von seinen
Team Kollegen er ist der Sieger von
Engelberg gewonnen aber dann ja ist dann
bisschen bisschen viel ja
Wahnsinn in einem hochklassigen
Skispringen mit schwierigen
Windbedingungen gelingen dem 33-Jährigen
zwei richtig gute Sprünge jeweils 135 m
genügend zum Sieg beim Weltcup in der
Schweiz der bislang beste deutsche im
Gesamtweltcup Andreas Wellinger hatte
nach dem ersten Durchgang geführt er
fällt mit einer Weite von 121hb met im
zweiten Versuch auf Rang 12 zurück
Zweiter hinter Paschke wird in Engelberg
der Norweger Marius lindwig Stefan Kraft
aus Österreich landet auf Rang
3 zweiter Triumf im zweiten monobob
Rennen beim Weltcup innsburg Eagles für
Lisa buckwitz die Olympiasiegerin
verwies keesa la aus den USA auf Platz 2
nicht ganz so gut lief es heute in
Lenzerheide für die Deutschen im
Biathlon weder bei den Frauen noch bei
den Männern reichte es in der Verfolgung
für das
Podest trotz starker Aufholjagd konnte
Franziska Preu sich nicht belohnen als
Siebte gestartet erlaubte sich die
Bayerin nur zwei Schießfehler beim
startzielsieg der Französin Justin BR
bouch kämpfte Preu hier mit Startnummer
7 bis zum Schluss verpasste aber ihren
dritten Podestplatz dann knapp
Enttäuschung dagegen bei den Männern
nach einer vielversprechenden
Ausgangslage ging die Deutschen en nach
etlichen Fehlern leer aus bester war
Philip Horn als Sieb Benedikt doll als
erster gestartet kam sogar nur auf Rang
17 Sieger einmal mehr der überragende
Johannes tinges B aus
Norwegen und zum Fußball großes
Entsetzen über die schweren
Ausschreitungen durch Rostocker
Randalierer während der zweitligatie
gestern Abend in paderbonn rund 150
gewalttätigge hansaanhänger hatten bei
der 0 Z3 Niederlage Pyrotechnik gezündet
Gegenstände auf isten geworfen und
massive Schäden im Stadion verursacht
das Spiel musste zweimal unterbrochen
werden es gab einige Verletzte harte
Strafen und Konsequenzen sollen
folgen und jetzt zur ersten Bundesliga
und den bisherigen Ergebnissen des 15
Spieltages nächster Dämpfer für Dortmund
1:1 in Augsburg Wolfsburg in Unterzahl
1:0 in Darmstadt wichtiger Erfolg für
Aufsteiger Heidenheim 1:0 in Mainz
Bochum deklassiert Union Berlin 3: ull
im Abendspiel empfängt Leipzig
Hoffenheim gestern gladbachbremen 2:2
erst morgen ist das Spitzentrio dran
Tabellenführer Leverkusen gegen
Frankfurt und im Verfolgerduell die
Bayern gegen Stuttgart in der oberen
Tabellenhälfte also kaum Veränderungen
der BVB nur mit einem Punktgewinn bleibt
fünfter Wolfsburg rutscht hoch auf neun
verdrängt Augsburg in die untere Hälfte
auf 10 sowie Gladbach auf 11 Heidenheim
und Bochum schieben sich vor Bremen
Union wieder auf FT nun direkt vor Mainz
und Darmstadt auf den Abstiegsplätzen
und ausführlich alles im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr in dem Bundestrainer
Julian nagelsmann zu Gast ist klingt gut
unbedingt vielen Dank Christin das
Wetter bringt am dritten Advent im
Norden etwas Regen sonst wird's entweder
trüb und kalt oder sonnig und mild wo
sie was erwarten können erklärt gleich
Katja
hornffer: begrüßt Sie Anne gellineck im
heute journal hier übernimmt
Siren alles Gute ihnen und auf bald
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend als antizyklonale
Kartoffel bezeichnet Frankreich das Hoch
Fiona wegen der kartoffelförmigen
Isobaren der Linien gleichen Luftdrucks
das hochfiona wird morgen ein bisschen
bisschen weiter nach Südosten ziehen für
uns bedeutet das entweder trübes kaltes
Wetter oder sonniges und mildes schon
heute lösten sich ja die Nebel und
Hochnebelfelder hier im Westen
Deutschlands am Nachmittag gut auf im
Norden lieb ist dagegen trüb und da fiel
auch ein bisschen Regen das wird auch in
der Nacht so weitergehen im Süden ist es
zum Teil klar zum Teil bildet sich schon
dicker Nebel und wenn es klar bleibt
dann wird's auch kalt dann sinken die
Werte auf -1 bis -4° im Norden bleibt
die Nacht bei 8 bis 6° milder und morgen
erwarten uns in Norddeutschland Temp
tempaturen von 7 bis 11° und im Süden
ist es komplett davon abhängig ob sie
sich auf den milden Höhen befinden oder
im Trüben kalten niebelgrau denn dort
steigen die Werte kaum über 2° hinaus
damit ist das Wetter auch schon erklärt
in Süddeutschland auf den Bergen gibt's
also viel Sonne in den Tälern Nebel in
Norddeutschland ist es einheitlicher
meist stark bewirkt bis bedeckt mit
etwas Regen in schleswig- Holstein und
dann geht es regnerisch in
Norddeutschland weiter und danach wird
es deutlich windiger ich wünsche ihn
einen schönen dritten Advent